[Music]
hmm
these days smash burgers are the air
jordans of the burger world
that is everywhere so for today's
challenge i
invited two experts burger scholar
george boats and home kitchen guru kenji
lopez alt
they're gonna show off their smash
burger skills and teach us some history
and technique along the way
and as always i've got a little
something special up my sleeve
here is your ultimate smash burger
master class
yo what's up guys what's up how's it
going good to see you
good to see you i wish we could see each
other in person but this will have to do
how's everybody doing doing good yeah
keeping busy
that's good hustle alive making food
making burgers excellent excellent well
today
our episode is all about the smash
burger smash burgers are the new
standard
of of burger making it's the craze right
now
why do you think that is well i would
say it's an old standard that's just
been sort of
recently repopularized yeah i mean i
think people are very nostalgic about
hamburgers
to begin with and i think that when
people start to realize that
hamburgers pre-date you know the fast
food guys like the mcburger kings
they went wait a minute this this stuff
is older than
than those fast food places 50s it goes
back to when it goes back
100 years or more you're actually
tasting history in there it kind of
maximizes flavor you know it's like
because you're getting so much of that
browning on there it's like eating like
a like a potato chip you know it's like
that that salt and that crunch
all three of us have different
approaches to the smash burger
and it would be great to to show
everyone our perspectives
you know for me it's i always just try
to come up with creative
weird ways and i have you know i have a
little something special for you guys to
to kind of show you what i've been
working on my burger's gonna be a little
it's gonna get a little weird too
i will definitely be the most
historically accurate that's for sure if
he's exactly accurate
no i may be in costume by the way
i can't wait to see what goes down
if we're going to talk about the history
of the burger we need to go
all the way back to the beginning
welcome to georgie burger can i get you
a hamburger
why do they talk like they're all irish
i don't know um today i'm going to make
for you the smash burger that would have
made 120 years ago
at the very beginning the dawn of the
hamburger age i got so excited about it
i even built a historically accurate
tent i had some
custom equipment made i had a special
spatula made
this one happens to be a barbecue fork
with a piece of metal attached to the
front of it
the beginning of the hamburger age was
all about making do with what you had
good again it's also hot as balls at air
the very first burgers that were made in
america were actually smash burgers
there were no paddy formers nothing was
standardized about the hamburger
business
at all one of the reasons that i love
the smash burger so much is because it
has a very very deep history
at the end of the 19th century
hamburgers really didn't exist in
restaurants
mostly you'd find them being served at
state fairs and from street carts which
were pulled to factory entrances
to feed the working class a small ball
of beef
would be placed in a skillet or handmade
shallow tank
and pressed into the shape of a patty
using a custom spatula
made quickly and cheaply as possible
these itinerant stands stained the
burger's image
and in 1906 when upton sinclair's
groundbreaking book the jungle
exposed the inner workings of the
meatpacking industry it spelled doom for
the hamburger
in 1919 white castle restored the image
of the lovely burger by emphasizing
safety and consistency
owners walt anderson and billy ingram
designed the restaurants in the shape of
castles
white signified cleanliness while castle
symbolized strength
inside you'd find young men wearing
clean white shirts and paper caps
rules restrict if their paper hats got
dirty
employees were instructed to throw them
away they went through so many caps that
in 1932
ingram started his own paper hat company
to supply the growing burger chain
the experience of eating at white castle
was all about spectacle
men would slide porcelain plates down
the counter as they called out your
order
allegedly coining the term slider in
their goal for efficiency
white castle standardized the burger bun
which helped usher in a scalable
fast food hamburger for the masses even
with the rise of white castle
many burger operations were still
cruelly constructed
the combination of makeshift tents and
pans filled with hot grease
with nowhere to dispose of it meant the
burger stands were in danger of going up
in flames at any moment
and often did new technology
revolutionized the slider
thanks to the invention of the grease
catch on flat tops
with these clean ultra hot surfaces
burger cooks could explore new methods
of preparation
leading to the rise of super crispy lacy
edge burgers from places like working
man's friend in indiana
and carl's drive in missouri that remain
hallmarks of this style to this very day
this is the story of the smash burger
[Music]
all right let's do this so what do i
have here i have
a tank now back in the day they would
have cooked in a skillet but at some
point they would have
graduated to a larger custom-made tank
just like this
because they realized that people
actually liked the flavor of beef that
was cooked
in tallow so this actually is a tank
that is full
of rendered beef fat so they would
literally put
the beef into the tallow
just like this you would do nothing more
than
press them into shape just like that
and that's how the hamburger was born
it's almost like we're deep frying the
burger here
also they would do this really cool
thing i've noticed in some of the old
pictures where they would keep
onions at the top corner of their tank
just sitting there kind of sitting in
the beef tallow ready to be used as a
very happy condiment and arguably the
only condiment for what i can tell
jesus doesn't come around for another 25
30 years
the guy was making hamburgers on the
street he would have had to go to a
local baker not you couldn't go
to the store and buy hamburger buns you
had to actually go buy dinner rolls
at a baker these were actually made by
my local baker caputo's bakery
in brooklyn step up and get the best
georgie oh [ __ ]
i'm covered in grease how did these guys
do this back then this is
back then it would have been five cents
turn of the century
but by 1910 i've noticed they were about
a ten cents per burger they would take
some
onions from the top of the griddle and
put them over there stick them over
there right
there we go put the butt on top
and there you go original american
hamburger right there
i've been transported i've gone back in
time
i find it fascinating that the smash
burger has gotten so
popular recently but i want to make sure
people understand
this is no fad the smash burger is the
first burger
georgie burgers only five cents
take it away alvin
mo showed us the history of a smash
burger but i'm gonna bring us back to
the present
wait for it ladies and gentlemen
it's called the flapper this is what is
this
the flapper you're basically just
folding over a smash patty
creating pockets of cheese that's almost
like a juicy lucy
it's almost like a hot pocket and when
you're biting into it
cheese just gushes out of it who doesn't
[ __ ] want that
i saw a burger at miz known where they
folded over like a taco
i thought that was super cool and then i
saw herds kind of just
smashing burgers like freestyle and i
thought that was super cool it was
texturally crunchy
juicy there still had some soft pieces
of beef in it and i wanted to have that
same
like flavor explosion in this particular
burger
let's get it i have these guys
but those aren't gonna cut it today
i'm calling in the big gun this is at
least five pounds of pure stainless
steel this is amboy burger blend it has
chuck it has brisket it has a whole
bunch of mind your business
you just basically drop it on the
griddle it has about
20 to 25 fat content and just start
smashing it
almost like an iron and then you're
going to taper it out
you want to get these nice crispy edges
so you're basically trying to get a
patty
that's smashed to about 10 inches round
you want
all of that surface area to get nice and
crispy if you can see
we have all that meat candy developing
at this point you just want to season it
with salt a little bit of pepper
we're going to flip this guy over
and now the undisputed burger cheese
american
on one side and on the caddy corner so
that when we flip the burger
all right the cheese is starting to melt
i'm going to fold it over one time
just like this so that is what's going
to turn into
the juicy lucy effect now the cheese is
trapped
in the patty and we're going to fold it
over one more time
we'll top it with one more piece of
cheese so you can see where the miz
known influence is coming from
you can see where the herds influence is
coming from
and there you have it i present to you
the flapper you got pockets of cheese
right there
if you give it a little squeeze you can
see all the cheese coming out
that's the juicy lucy effect you got all
this beautiful
my yard beef candy hanging
flapping from the edge of the burger
thousands of smashed burgers later this
is what i come up with
layers of meat pockets of cheese
let's see what you got kenji you're up
next
all right so alvin it looks like you
made a burger that is
all about crust and cheese pockets what
i'm trying to address is the
um the contrast between crustiness and
juiciness so when you make a smash
burger
it's all it's really all about that
mayard reaction about that browning and
about that nice beef crust that you get
on it but you also lose some of the um
the tender juicy texture of a thicker
pub style burger
so what i'm doing is i'm going to i'm
gonna i'm gonna make a burger that
addresses both those issues and then on
top of that i was thinking
all right the american cheese that's
another thing that some people have
issue with you know i love american
cheese because there's nothing that
melts like it
um so what i was thinking was all right
how can i take that cheese element but
i'll actually boost the beef what i'm
essentially doing here is i'm gonna make
beef cheese and what i have here so this
is a um basically a beef demi-glass this
is like the kind of sauce that you would
put on like a really fancy steak at a at
a restaurant this is this is like why
fancy food is expensive because there's
like
five pounds of beef bones reduced down
to like a half cup of
sauce here american cheese is made
with extra liquid and then a emulsifying
salt
so in this case i'm going to be using
sodium citrate and what sodium citrate
does
is that it allows the cheese to remain
emulsified even when it's melted
and this is just like a um a mild
cheddar so i'm gonna add
about a teaspoon sodium citrate here and
then i'm just gonna start whisking in my
cheese
this is like basically beef flavored
nacho cheese dip now so now i've got
this plastic wrap on the bottom of a
sheet tray like this
i'm just going to pour my cheese mixture
over it
i'm going to run down and put this in
the in the walk-in or in the fridge so
that it can set up and then i'll come
right back and we can start making the
actual burgers i'm gonna make two
different burger patties so one
a juicy patty with a slice of beef
cheese and
on stacked on top of that a smash patty
so i'm gonna start by doing the the
thicker burger so this is going to be
like a
about a four ounce patty the outside of
a burger always cooks more than the
middle does which means that it
constricts more and so what happens is
it kind of cinches up like a belt
so by forming it with a little bit of an
indentation in the center
you make sure that that doesn't happen a
little bit of oil in the pan
i like to use a skillet that is you know
just bigger than the size of the burger
because you want that pat where at least
i want the fat to kind of
pool up a little bit so that the
burger's really cooking in its own fat
there
and so for the smash patty i'm going
with about a little over two ounces of
beef
all right while that rests we're gonna
take this back there
all right so um so back here i'm gonna
start with um my bun on the flat top and
i'm using just some of our
garlic mayo here to toast the bun the
keys with toasting a bun
is that you want to really move it
around because that's what's going to
get you the nice even toast
so the key to a good smash burger
is a dry griddle you don't want any oil
on there because you actually want the
burger to stick
at the beginning for a long time i had
trouble with smash burgers sticking to
the bottom of the spatula so what we do
now is we have these little sheets of
parchment paper
give it a smash and i smash like kind of
around in a circle
so that the edges spread out a little
bit and then this is the real key that
um a wallpaper scraper which we get from
the hardware store
with a razor blade on it
so that's how you get those nice nice
lacy edges here
all that stuff there that's what we're
looking for all right so we're gonna get
this back on the other side
assemble our burger with our cheese
okay so i got my burgers my cheese is
all set
finish off this burger by basting that
cheese a little bit with the hot
burger drippings to get it nice and
melty stack our smash patty on top
let's do one last slice of beef cheese
on top of that
give that guy a quick base
last swipe of mayo i like laying like a
nice little bed of stuff
for the beef because then you know that
way anything that drips out it kind of
seasons the toppings underneath and make
sure it doesn't
all slide around all right
[Music]
again you know with a burger you know
the smash burger the brownie that you're
getting
so that that's mayard browning right
it's a it's a reaction that's named
after a french scientist who discovered
these reactions what's happening
essentially is that there's proteins and
carbohydrates um
in the meat that uh break down and so
they they start out as complex
structures and then they break down into
basic building blocks and then the heat
triggers this sort of series of
chemical reactions like a cascade of
reactions that forms hundreds of new
flavor compounds and that's why
you know meat that's browned or bread
that has a nice brown crust you know
when you toast your bread
it takes on a much more complex flavor
because you're actually
creating hundreds of new compounds that
add complexity
to that meat all right so we got our
nice
medium rare fat patty underneath our
layers of beef cheese and then that
crispy smash burger on top
i'm actually surprised at how good this
is this is the first time i actually
made this to completion
in my head it sounded good but it tastes
better than i even thought it would
taste
and i don't know what we call this
burger the the double joy i don't know
so there you have it folks it's the
smash burger episode of the burger show
and we will see you next time
what's up everybody thank you for
watching the burger show make sure you
hit that like button
make sure you smash that subscribe
button hit that notification bell
if not for me for the burgers thank you